al contar de 100 en 100 de 250 a 1050
que en números dirías elige todas las
opciones correctas y como siempre los
invito a que pausa en el vídeo y traten
de resolver esto por su cuenta antes de
ver cómo lo solucionamos aquí lo primero
que voy a hacer es escribir el número
desde el que voy a iniciar mi conteo 250
y a esta cantidad le voy a estar
agregando 100 unidades cada vez entonces
tengo 250 a 250 le agrego 100 le estoy
agregando una centena más entonces ahora
voy a tener dos centenas más una centena
tres centenas y estos 50 se mantienen
igual no cambian las decenas ni las
unidades
a 350 le agrego 100 voy a tener ahora 4
centenas 450
y así voy a estar dándole seguimiento a
las centenas con este otro color a 450
le agrego 100 van a ser 550
a 500 le agregamos 100 51 más una
centena 6 606 centenas 5 decenas y 0
unidades
seguimos ahora a este 650 le agregamos
100 va a ser 750
a esas siete centenas le agregamos una
más nuestros 100 van a ser 8 centenas 5
decenas y 0 unidades ya vamos por menos
a estas 8 centenas le agrego una centena
más van a ser 9 centenas o 950 así esta
cantidad y finalmente a estas 9 centenas
les voy a agregar una centena más ahora
van a ser 10 centenas
5 decenas y 0 unidades o como ya aquí
llegamos a los millares va a ser 1050
esta cantidad que tenemos al final ahora
vamos a ver de estos números que
contamos cuáles son los que encontramos
acá el 122 pues nos ni de chiste porque
250 es más grande que 122 así que no
iniciamos contando lo éste no esté ahora
cual sigue 350 si aquí tengo 350 este si
después tengo 650 y aquí tengo 650 éste
también lo menciona ahora a 675 este no
porque estábamos contando recién en 100
a partir de 250 no agregamos decenas
entonces no había forma de que de 50
pasáramos al 75 así que éste
el que sigue 750 si este si lo tengo
contemplado acá
aquí está
y esto lo pudieron haber hecho
mentalmente también a partir de 250 le
agregan un 1 a esta parte de las
centenas y van 250 350 que está 1 450
550 650 aquí está el otro 750 de hecho
aquí está éstos vimos que no aplican
entonces mentalmente sin tener que haber
escrito todo esto pudimos haber
encontrado las opciones correctas pero
así escrito queda bastante más claro